there's a lot of cool trivia out there
about Darth Vader the most legendary
villain in the Star Wars universe did
you know it took five separate actors
bring Luke's father to life in the
original flick or the James Earl Jones
wasn't credited as the voice of Vader
until Return of the Jedi that kind of
knowledge might help you win a pub quiz
but it's just scratching the surface
let's talk about some deep cuts here are
some facts about the Sith Lord only true
Vader nerds no dark ubiquitous Vader is
the only human character to appear in
every main Star Wars feature film in
some way shape or form not Han not Leia
not Luke not Porkins unfortunately only
the half-human cyborg Darth Vader can
claim that title will be useless lucious
obviously Vader's villainy was central
to the original trilogy and his origin
story formed the entire backbone of the
prequels but thirty years after Darth
Vader's death within the Star Wars
universe
he remains so important that even showed
up in Episode seven or at least his
mangled helmet did and also made a
stunning appearance in 2016 rogue one
which brings us to Darth expeditious
although the Sith Lords appearance on
screen midway through rogue one was
written into the script from the get-go
his most incredible scene came at the
very end and foreshadowed Vader's reign
of terror in the original trilogy to
come an intense hallway battle sequence
in which it besieged ship full of rebels
raced to escape whether stolen
blueprints to the Death Star all while
Vader advanced on them lightsaber in
hand cutting down every last man with
casual brutality it's an incredible
moment made that much more remarkable
because it was tacked on at the last
possible moment after rogue one editor
argued Vader needed more screen time
director Gareth Edwards said editor
Jabba's Olson thought one more badass
moment was called for but Olsen Simon
was awful the film was about four months
from release ultimately the sequence was
shot in three days an incredible feat
since it ended up being among the best
and most memorable scenes in the entire
film
Darth repetitious Vader was downright
terrifying and rogue
but if you look closely at his deadly
stroll down that hallway you'll realize
you've seen all these moves before they
didn't teach an old dog new tricks but I
think we'll be done lord Vader he
deflects laser blast uses the force to
lift and choke as well as disarm and
there's of course the lightsaber hacking
and slashing we all know and love while
it might have been tempting to give the
old-school Vader a new trick or two
according to director Gareth Edwards
keeping his deadly skillset familiar was
the Golden Rule everything you sort of
see him doing down that corridor is
pretty much something from the previous
films which is why Vader wasn't
breakdance fighting or shooting
fireballs good call
Darth minimus forget that handless farm
boy Luke Skywalker
Vader's the real star of the series
having left his mark on every episode
and been some but did you know that the
franchise has fallen hero the most
iconic villain in all of sci-fi was in
the first movie for fewer than 10
minutes 10 minutes that's like half a
fresh Prince episode without the
commercials which in a one little slide
II may watch all those scared
Michiko Watanabe and uncle in bel-air it
feels like he's in the film for much
longer which is a testament to how
effective those 10 minutes were in
introducing such an enigmatic and
menacing character compare that to the
insufferable 17 minutes plus we had to
spin with Jar Jar Binks in episode 1
it's enough to make you want to force
choke yourself to death thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all the cool stuff we know you
love to
[Music]